[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débats de
chroniqu et de reportage on est ensemble
pour 90 minutes du lundi au jeudi à 18h
et 22h sur Public Sénat et voici le
sommaire de ce 30 octobre la guerre
urbaine a commencé à Gaza de violents
combats au sol ont opposé aujourd'hui
l'armée israélienne aux hommes du Hamas
quelle est la stratégie de tsal qui
annonce avoir libéré une soldat otage du
Hamas la pression des alliés de l'État
hébreu pèse-t-elle sur l'ampleur de
cette opération terrestre l'échange a
Tage contre prisonnier proposé par
l'organisation terroriste palestinienne
est-il réalisable on répond à toutes ces
questions avec nos invités expert dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
débat c'est le rôle de l'Iran que nous
allons scruter l'Iran qui menace par la
voix du Guide suprême l'ayatollah
rameney si les crimes du régime sioniste
se poursuivent les musulmans et les
forces de résistance s'impatienteront et
personne ne pourra les
arrêté mais derrière ces menaces le
régime des Mola fragilisé par plus d'un
an de révolte de sa jeunesse peut-il
prendre le risque d'un embrasement du
conflit au Proche Orient réponse dans 3
qu4 d'heure mais d'abord le récit de la
2è phase de la ripost israélienne avec
audre
vetaz ces images fournies par l'Agence
France press montrent que l'armée
israélienne est arrivée au sud de
gazaville nous sommes dans le quartier
de Zitoun cette voiture blanche tente de
faire demi-tour elle est pulvérisée par
un char israélien dans le véhicule qui
filme la scène les passagers hurlent aux
autres conducteurs de prendre la
fuite depuis vendredi tal multiplie les
incursions terrestres dans la bande de
Gaza de violentsb au sol sont en cours
et sur ces images fournies par l'armée
israélienne les raides aériens
s'intensifient si S cible auraient été
frappé avec un but anéantir le
Hamas nous avons étendu nos opérations
dans la bande de Gaza avec des forces
supplémentaires des chars de
l'artillerie nos soldats ont éliminé des
dizaines de terroristes qui s'étaient
barricadés dans des bâtiments et qui
tent de les
attaquer des combats qui devrai se
poursuivre alors que l'enclave est jours
assiégé ce matin l'ONU a annoncé
l'entrée de 33 camions humanitaires dans
Gaza vient le point de passage de Rafa à
la frontière égyptienne c'est le plus
important qu'on voit depuis 10 jours une
aide insuffisante préviennent les
nations-
unies la situation à Gaza devient plus
désespérée d'heure en heure je regrette
qu'au lieu de la trêve humanitaire
urgente que demande la communauté
internationale Israël a intensifié ses
opérations militaires le nombre de
civils tués et blessés est totalement
inacceptable la guerre entre Israël et
le Hamas menace d'enflammer la région
les tensions restent vives à la
frontière avec le Liban Israël aurait
aussi frappé plusieurs cibles en Syrie
en réponse à des tirs de
roquettes et on débat autour de la
stratégie de l'armée israélienne avec
Emmanuel dupui bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes président de l'Institut prospective
et sécurité en Europe et enseignant en
géopolitique Patricia lémonier bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi grand reporteur
spécialiste des relation international
ancienne correspondante pour TF1 en
Israël et vous publiez au cœur du chaos
aux éditions
to j'accue Jean-Paul chagnolo bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes professeur
des universités président de l'Institut
de recherche et d'études Méditerranées
Moyen-Orient et Mathieu croissandau
éitorialiste politique bonsoir Mathieu
bonsoir à tous bienvenue à vous cette
dernière nouvelle que je glissais dans
dans dans les titre communication de
l'armée israélienne en cette fin
d'après-midi de lundi qui annonce avoir
libéré une soldate retenu par le Hamas
euh opération qui selon a été mené dans
la nuit de dimanche à lundi Emmanuel
Dupuis il il y a une force symbolique le
fait d'avoir libéré un en l'occurrence
une femme soldat oui mais la symbolique
arrive quand même tard puisque c'est
quasiment 23 jours après le
déclenchement de l'opération menée en
Israël avec déjà des critiques par
rapport à la durée de cette opération ou
le temps mis pour la mettre en place
évidemment elle est lourde ça
il y a eu le rappel de 300000
réservistes pour agir autour de la bande
de Gaza ils vont pas tous évidemment
pénétrer dans la bande de Gaza avec des
interrogations sur la finalité si l'on
écoute le chef d'état-major RZ Alevi qui
a expliqué les la manière dont les
opérations allaient être menées on n'
pas senti qu'il y avait une
planification à très long terme il y a
une planification à court terme essayer
de libérer les otages les quelques 220
otages dont certains militaires essayer
évidemment d'éradiquer c'est le terme
qui a été employé par GAV galante le
mise à défense les structures du Hamas
avec près de plusieurs milliers de
frappes hein on je crois qu'on en est à
600 frappes plus précisément avec des
opérations qui sont menées tactiquement
mais sans qu'on sache vraiment quelle
est la finalité une occupation de Gaza
comme avant 2005 la reprise du blocus
israélo-égyptien faut-il le rappeler
parce que l'Égypte pratique aussi ce ce
ce blocus tout simplement quelle sera la
finalité d'une reprise d'un dialogue
avec une entité qui restera déterminée
par rapport au sort de gazaou après le
combat et on se protège on se projettera
évidemment un peu plus à long terme dans
dans la dernière partie de ce débat
Patricia Lemmonier c'est c'est
effectivement pas l'opération on va dire
massive qui avait été imaginée quasiment
annoncée au dans dans un premier temps
pourquoi ce revirement on va dire alors
je crois que dans un premier temps
l'armée israélienne a fait ce qui se
pratique ces derniers temps par toutes
les armées c'est-à-dire des
bombardements massifs et puis
effectivement tout le monde attendait
cette opération militaire massive de
d'entrer dans Gaza avec occupation et
recherche comme vous l'avez dit du Hamas
et l'éradication du Hamas ça ne s'est
pas fait peut-être pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est la pression
quand même américaine qui reste forte
parce que les Américains avaient besoin
de temps et demander aux Israéliens
d'avoir de prendre du temps et donc
cette pression a semble-t-il fonctionné
euh la deuxième raison c'est a je pense
que les Israéliens n'ont pas voulu
refaire ce qu'ils avaient fait
précédemment parce que le Hamas a appris
des différentes opérations Plomb Durci
c'est l'opération sur la bordure je sais
plus le nom bordure infranchissable je
crois c'est ça du M voilà et donc ils
ont chaque fois appris ils ont compris
les techniques de l'armée israélienne et
là on voit bien que c'est c'est très
différent effectivement c'est des
modules qui rentrent qui les deux trois
premiers jours sont rentrés puis sont
ressortis et là c'est des modules qui
qui restent sur place et maintenant qui
avancent et diton une fois que ils
auront ils cherchent du renseignement
enfin c'est ce qui nous arrive par par
l'armée israélienne il cherche à capter
à voir même des prisonniers là on peut
peut-être penser qu'avec la soldate
libérée il y a peut-être eu des
prisonniers on ne sait pas ils cherchent
à avoir des prisonniers et obtenir du
renseignement pour savoir pour étayer
effectivement tout ce qu'ils ont déjà
acquis comme connaissance en ce qui
concerne les tunnels on peut penser que
l'opération qui avait été menée à Rafa
où il y a eu un tunnel enfin il y a eu
des une opération maritime effectivement
a fait suite à une prise de guerre en
quelque sorte par l'armée israélienne en
mer vous avez fait ils avaient pris un
important responsable dixit du Hamas
donc et la troisème phase serait cette
phase attendue euh de l'offensive
terrestre et le dernier élément que je
je veux dire pourquoi aussi pas tout de
suite et bien parce que déclencher cette
opération c'était franchir cette fameuse
ligne rouge qui était pour les Iraniens
et pour le hzbollah bien déterm é une
une opération massive aurait rendu très
difficile au Hezbollah et à l'Iran de ne
pas réagir ne pas réagir plus fortement
qu'il ne le font déjà on écoute je vous
donne la parole juste après on écoute le
porte-parole de de tsal Daniel hagari
qui explique un peu la montée en
puissance on va dire ça comme ça de
l'intervention militaire israélienne
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche nous
avons augmenté le nombre des forces de
l'armée à entrer dans la bande de Gaza
et elles se sont jointes à celles qui se
battent déjà là-bas graduellement les
opérations terrestres et l'étendue de
nos forces dans la bande de Gaza
Jean-Paul chagolo c'est c'est difficile
de parler d'une d'une repost graduée
quand on quand on voit les les les les
victimes civiles évidemment mais est-ce
que malgré tout on on vous vous êtes
d'accord sur cette idée qu'il y a une
pression internationale qui a peut-être
limité la riposte israélienne je crois
que on assiste plutôt à une montée en
impuissance quoi pour beaucoup de
raisons la première c'est celle que vous
évoquez effectivement il faudrait pas
oublier les otages israélien la pression
des familles qui estim qu'il faut
d'abord libérer les otages et c'est très
fort il y a eu tout c'était il y a 48
heur une rencontre avec netaniaahou et
des familles il y a évidemment la
pression des différentes capitales par
rapport à cette question et puis
globalement quand je dis monter en
impuissance je veux dire que même
Emmanuel Macron qui est un peu cafouillé
pendant quelques temps a dit très
clairement il y a deux jours 3 jours que
cette offensive globale s'il devait
avoir lieu est une erreur euh Biden bien
plutôt a dit ne faites pas nos erreurs
c'està-dire qu'on est on est on pour en
faire quoi en quelque sorte c'est
c'estàd que en fait on est on est dans
cette comment dirais-je dans dans dans
dans ce discours militaire avec des
pseudo tactiques mais sans aucun aucun
objectif politique véritable dans harest
il y a 2 jours il y avait il y avait un
article très intéressant qui a dit
quelle est la stratégie d'Israël par
rapport à ça et la réponse de du
chroniqueur était le vide et c'est vrai
ils hésitent en plus il y a des
contradictions au sein du cabinet de
guerre sans parler évidemment de la
position de Netanyahou qui est pour le
moins disons déséquilibre pour parler de
manière très très élégante quoi en
réalité beaucoup veulent sa peau si on
prend un autre langage donc je crois
qu'on et puis et puis y a un deuxième
volet qui est extrêmement important
votre votre photo juste derrière
elle illustre quoi elle illustre des
destruction mais elle illustre des
milliers de morts et je je viens d' d'un
ministère important là je viens d'un
ministère important où on m'a donné des
informations sur ce qui se passe et
c'est absolument tragique ce que vient
dire guteres il y a il y a des des
milliers et des milliers de morts et
donc ça quand et quand on va le voir là
on le voit de manière parcellaire mais
quand on va le voir vraiment on va se
rendre contre de de de de cette énorme
tragédie qui est en train de se passer
et et qui va être forcément
contreproductive alors évidemment pour
les israélien mais pas seulement je
pense que ça peut aussi conduire à on a
entendu tout à l'heure le guide bon le
guide il dit ce qu'il veut mais c'est
clair que s'il y a effectivement une
tragédie de cette importance je vois mal
Hezbollah rester sur sur la comme ça en
en position avant avant d'intervenir
donc on est en cette situation qui est
au fond une situation de grande de
grande ambiguïé et je crois que la seule
chose qui devrait être faite c'est de
suivre la résolution des Nations Unies
et avoir des trêves humanitaires et et
se mettre à réfléchir en terme politique
on en reparlera un peu plus tard de
cette résolution est-ce qu'on sait ce
que ça veut dire éradiquer le Hamas euh
on se souvient que quand euh euh les
États-Unis voulaient faire tomber le
régime iraakien ils avaient sorti
d'esèce de jeu de cartes souvenez avec
les 40 euh ou les 50 plus gros
personnages de de du système Saddam
Hussein est-ce que est-ce qu'on a une
une cartographie comme ça enfin pas pas
des cartes à jouer mais est-ce qu'on a
un organigramme est-ce qu'on sait le
nombre de personnes est-ce
queu ils ont déjà commencé alors
l'éradication concerne la branche
militaire pour l'instant il y a eu si je
ne m'abuse le chef des opération
l'adjoint du renseignement du Hamas qui
a été éliminé ou le chef des opérations
aériennes qui était présenté par zal
comme étant à l'origine du commando par
contre et c'est là où il y a peut-être
une vraie interrogation à aucun moment
je n'ai entendu dire qu'il fallait
éradiquer r méchal qu'il fallait é adcté
Ismal anier qu'il fallait éradiquer la
BR abouzou qui était il y a quelques
jours à Moscou la branche politique qui
se trouve accessirement pas à Gaza qui
se trouve soit en Turquie ou à DOA ou
qui se trouve en train de faire des
diplomaties alternatives je rappelle que
le numéro 2 du Hamas a été reçu par
Sergey Lavrov il y a quelques heures
Moscou et de toute façon
cette éradication il faut rappeler ce
qu'est le Hamas en quelques mots on le
sait maintenant parce qu'il beaucoup de
beaucoup de débats là-dessus mais enfin
c'est une organisation qui est
profondément enracinée dans le peuple
palestinien et donc même si on éradique
quelques chefs et même si on va plus
loin dans la structure militaire il
n'empêche que il y aura d'autres
personnes qui viendront quoi qu'il
arrive al ça sera pas dans 6 mois ça
sera dans 2 ans juste un exemple très
concret pendant la seconde tifada on a
assassiné les principaux chefs et en
particulier le fondateur qui est le
cherassine et bien à côté de lui il y
avait il y avait un collaborateur qui
s'appelait Ismaël anier bon c'était le
collaborateur aujourd'hui c'est le
patron il y avait ensuite rantii rantii
a été assassiné dans les quelques
semaines qui ont suivi ainsi de suite
donc c'est il y AA forcément et et ce
qui se passe là ce qui se passe là la
tragédie le bombardement qu'est-ce que
ça va faire pour pour les jeunes
Palestiniens ça va faire autant de gens
qui seront prêts à à
reconstruire c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il faut impérativement du politique
làdedans sinon on va on va ouais mais
est-ce qu'on pe on peut imaginer à terme
négocier avec euh des personnalités
palestinennes qui se réclamament des
ramasse Patricia alors là pour l'instant
je pense que pour les Israéliens ils
sont dans le temps de la guerre et on
est nous malheureusement très souvent en
Occident dans le temps de l'émotion
autour de cette guerre et il n'y a pas
effectivement de pensée sauf à ressortir
la vieille idée des deux États qui
franchement si on devait la mettre en
place aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle
serait assez difficile vu l'imbrication
qu'il y a en S Jordanie sujet sur lequel
on reviendra peut-être mais on a que
cette idée à mettre en avant aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas d'autres perspective donc
je crois que pour l'instant
effectivement ce qui manque beaucoup
actuellement c'est des responsables
j'entends des vrais responsables
politiques et je ne pense pas que ça
soit le chef de l'Autorité palestinienne
et peut-être les chefs du Hamas qui sont
au Qatar parce que je crois que les
Israéliens ne seraient pas prêts à
discuter avec eux pour l'instant bien
que parfois on classe de terroristes
certaines personnes et après on en fait
des chefs d'État et on discute avec eux
mais je je referme cette parenthèse mais
il n'y a pas de de personnalité côté
palestinien sauf à à ressortir de prison
quelqu'un comme bargouti respecté dans
dans toute la région et dans toute la la
Palestine au sens large du terme Gaza
compris sauf à ressortir cette personne
dont les Israéliens ne veulent pas
entendre parler quant à côté côté
israélien je ne vois pas de personnalité
non plus qui émerge et qui soit capable
d'envisager un futur donc la question
est très difficile quand on écoute le
discours
du Premier ministre israélien mais il
est toujours dans son dans ses discours
complètement messianique de la lutte
contre l'Occident qui incarne le bien
vis-à-vis du Mal incarné par le
djihadisme islamique il est toujours
dans cette rhtorique rhtorique qu' qui
dont il s'inspire depuis son premier
livre qu'il a écrit je vous rappelle en
1981 il parle je crois de 2uxème guerre
d'indépendance aujourd'hui sont les les
termes employé par vous avez raison
c'est un discours très messianique qui
fait référence à des temps bibliques
temp h catacsmique d'Illes le discours
était assez sombre mais pour répondre
aussi d'une autre manière à votre à
votre question s'il s'agissait
d'éradiquer le Hamas et ben il y a aussi
une autre façon de le faire c'est de
couper les financements du Hamas ou
d'essayer de trouver les numér les
nombreux comptes on dit qu'ils sont une
une des organisations terroristes les
plus richement dotées près de 1 milliard
de dollars donc on sait les circuits
financiers peut-être pour revenir à un
débat qu'on a ici qu'on a eu ici la
semaine dernière cette fameuse dualité
avec La coalion Mondiale contre daesh là
pour le coup elle a été efficace dans la
manière dont on a tracé et dont on a
finalement coupé assécher FL financiers
peut-être que ça serait une
façon la vraie je pense que pour
vraiment éradiquer le Hamas vous savez
on parle de la guerre on parle de moyens
des sanctions mais la vraie la vraie
question je je reviens toujours à la
même chose elle est politique la vraie
façon d'éradiquer le Hamas et tout ce
qui se passe ça serait la paix et c'est
pas c'est pas utopique si vous prenez ce
qui s'est passé pendant les quelques
années du processus d'Oslo si nous
renvoie à la Préhistoire pratiquement et
bien l'influence du Hamas était à peu
près proportionnelle du niveau
d'avancement du processus de paix dès
que le processus de paix ont pensait
qu'il allait arriver l'influence du
Hamas baissait et d'ailleurs il devenait
plus violent donc je veux dire que si si
on avait un processus de paix ce type
d'action serait forcément marginalisé
pourquoi est-ce que les jeunes se
précipitent de pour aller faire de la ce
qu'ils appellent la résistance armée ben
c'est précisément qu'il y a pas d'autres
horizon donc si on leur offre un autre
horizon ce qui est évidemment dans la
configuration actuelle tout à fait
utopique mais si on le offre un autre
horizon ils iront moi quand dernière
fois que j'ai j'ai vu c'était pas
longtemps j'étais avec des jeunes
Palestiniens ils m'ont dit alors c'était
en 6 c'était pas à Gaza parce que on
pouvait pas y aller et je le disais mais
quel est comment vous voyez votre avenir
et alors il m'emmène à quelques
centaines de mètres de là il y avait un
cimetière il dit voilà où est mon avenir
voilà O est mon avenir des jeunes qui
avaient peut-être 17 18 ans c'est en
diton si vous voulez sur l'état de
désespérance car il faut rappeler une
chose que depuis 2009 minimum netanahou
a toujours systématiquement refusé le
moindre compromis politique et toujours
répondu par la force et c'est ça qui est
dramatique on est dans le paroxisme de
la force là et j'ai peur que ça aille
très très loin si la communauté
internationale ne retient pas comme elle
essaie de le faire cette offensive et
tout ce qui va avec effectivement et
notamment ces victimes civiles dont on
parlait je vous propose un témoignage un
habitant de Rafa il s'appelle Tair
Achour
tous les jours nous voyons la même chose
des enfants de moins de de ou 3
ans des bébés d'un ou de mois des femmes
de 60 ans des personnes de plus de 50
ans où sont les combattants qu' visent
ce sont des abris où sont gardés des
bébés qui n'ont même pas encore vu le
monde le procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale s'est rendu à arf
Patricia lmonier au poste-frontière
entre le l'Égypte et Gaza quand sur
quels actes il va pouvoir enquêter après
vous la Cour pénale internationale seule
habilité finalement à définir crime de
guerre ou crime contre l'humanité est
capable dans de d'enquêter elle peut la
la le rythme de la justice est lent mais
elle peut le faire puisqu'il y a déjà un
processus d'enquête en cours simplement
il faut savoir qu'effectivement Israël
ne reconnaît pas la Cour pénale
internationale que l'Autorité
palestinienne à l'inverse la reconnaît
je ne parle pas du Hamas je ferme la
parenthèse sur le Hamas mais euh alors
certains disent c'est inutile puisque
Israël ne ne ne ne reconnaît pas euh je
vous signalerai simplement que la Russie
ne n'a pas non plus signé euh et ne
reconnaît pas non plus la Cour pénale
internationale et pourtant Vladimir
Poutine est bien poursuivi par la Cour
pénale internationale donc le problème
c'est le temps de la justice c'est c'est
deux temps différents et le temps de la
justice il est nécessaire je crois il
est nécessaire mais l'urgence est quand
même aujourd'hui malgré tout à l'arrêt
des
tues et donc il faut que la la Cour
pénale peut se saisir effectivement
enfin il y a déjà une enquête qui est
déclenchée au niveau de onusien mais
l'urgence aujourd'hui elle se saisit de
quoi exactement à la fois à la fois des
attaques terroristes du
Hamas
frappes ce n'est pas spécifié à Hamas et
Israël mais c'estes crimes de guerre
dans le conflit donc ça sous-entend les
deux juste un mot pour pour ce qui est
de la compétence il faut être
extrêmement
clair la Cour pénale est compétente
quand il s'agit de citoyen d'un État qui
a signé et qui est partie prenant de la
c bien accusé ça c'est le prier cas et
le deuxième cas c'est lorsque un crime
est commis sur le territoire d'un État
qui est signataire en l'occurrence la
Palestine est un état reconnu par la C
après son adhésion enfin comme État non
membre aux Nations Unies en 2012 et par
conséquent le territoire délimité qui
est Gaza Jérusalem Est et la sis
jouranie donc tout ce qui est va être
fait sur ce territoire et bien la Cour
pénale est parfaitement compétente pour
enquéter et éventuellement pour ouvrir
une donc il faut bien distinguer donc
ils sont parfaitement compétents rentrer
dans le détail je
m sur plan judique bien merci à tous les
deux de ces précisions mais si on
reprend quand même l'argument l'un des
arguments de donné par euh le le cabinet
de guerre sur ces frappes aériennes
notamment il y a l'argument de de dire
que le Hamas utilise par exemple les
hôpitaux comme QG caché et donc utilise
les les civils en comme bouclier comme
bouclier est-ce que est-ce qu'on sait
est-ce qu'on peut prouver ça qu'est-ce
qu'on en sait aujourd'hui en tout cas
selon le droit international de la
guerre ou le droit humanitaire c'est ces
deux termes auquels a fait référence le
président Emmanuel Macron ciblé des C
contre oui l'argum d'Isral il cible pas
des civils il cherche
à dirigeants du Hamas et qui se
cachp sur le principe même de la
détermination des lieux selon le droit
international on ne cible pas des
hôpitaux des écoles et des civils ça
c'est inscrit dans les gênes du droit
international depuis la Convention de
Genève les Conventions de Genève de 1949
et les protocol additionnel de 7 par
contre pour revenir sur la CPI c'est une
question très intéressante parce qu'elle
va être très politisée un peu comme en
Ukraine autant la compétence
territoriale a été prouvé la Palestine
est signataire du Statut de Rome en 1998
c'est la durée des exactions et il s'est
posé la même question en Ukraine à
partir de quand on commence les enquêtes
est-ce qu'on commence les enquêtes en
2014 pour l'Ukraine ou en 2022 est-ce
qu'on commence les enquêtes à partir de
1948 allons jusqu'au bout ou est-ce
qu'on commence non non non c'est à
partir du moment où la convention a été
signée par conséqu çaut pas ça peut pas
aller au-delà de 2012 c'est extrê
clair partant du principe que la deème
antifada ou à partir de ça peut pas
entrer dans le champ des enquêtes ça
peut être que à partir du moment où
l'État a signé bien sûr
juste 2012
2012 simplement il faut savoir que juste
avant que la guerre cette guerre se
déclenche il y avait tout un dossier
très épais que devait présenter mon
justement à la Cour pénale
internationale le Hamas sur les crimes
de guerre commis par Israël on va parler
de l'hypothèse d'une trêve humanitaire
Mathieu la France a voté vendredi un
appel en ce sens trê humanitaire
immédiate c'était lors de l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies oui alors
c'est une résolution qui a fait beaucoup
parler qui a divisé aussi et que la
France a décidé donc d'adopter par
l'intermédiaire de son ambassadeur aux
Nations Unies Nicolas de rivière c'était
vendredi soir à New York alors pour bien
comprendre que pour il faut expliquer à
nos téléspectateurs que ça fait
maintenant plusieurs jours que le
Conseil de sécurité de son côté échoue à
faire adopter une résolution
contraignante sur le conflit il y a eu
quatre tentatives qui sont soldées par
quatre échecs pas tellement en fonction
de ce que les textes disent mais plutôt
en fonction de ce qu'ils ne disent pas
et surtout en fonction de qui les
propose la France a ainsi voté contre un
appel à un cesser le feu humanitaire le
16 octobre il était proposé par la
Russie car plusieurs éléments essentiels
manquaient à justifier Nicolas de
rivière l'ambassadeur aux nations- Unies
et et notamment une condamnation de
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas ensuite
elle s'est abstenue lors d'un vote sur
une seconde proposition russe qui était
plus explicite celle-ci la vérité
diplomatique c'est surtout que Paris il
y a pas tellement envie de voter pour
une proposition portée par Moscou et à
l'inverse la France a voté pour une
résolution américaine mais qui a été
rejetée celle-ci en en raison du véteau
russe et chinois et puis elle a voté
pour aussi une résolution portée par le
Brésil qui appelait à des pauses
humanitaires pour fournir de l'aide à
des millions de personnes dans la dans
la bande de Gaza mais qui cette fois-ci
a été rejeté par les États-Unis qui ont
reproché au texte toujours de pas
mentionné alors là c'était le droit
d'Israël à se défendre alors qu'est-ce
qui a changé dans le texte de vendredi
ben d'abord le lieu c'est pas le Conseil
de sécurité c'est l'assemblée générale
du coup il y avait pas de c'est pas une
histoire de droit de vétoau et mais
aussi c'est pas une résolution
contraignante c'est un texte qui était
porté par la Jordanie au nom d'un groupe
de 22 pays le groupe arabe il demande
une trêve humanitaire immédiate durable
et soutenue menant à la cessation des
hostilités et il met l'accent sur la
nécessité de d'ouvrir un accès sans
entrave à l'acheminement d'aide donc de
l'eau de la nourriture des médicaments
du carburant de l'électricité le texte
condamne tous les actes de violence
dirigés contre des civils palestiniens
et israéliens notamment tous les actes
de terrorisme et les attaques sans
discernement et puis il se dit aussi
vivement préoccupé par la dernière
escalade de la violence depuis l'attaque
du 7 octobre mais il ne mentionne pas
explicitement le Hamas ni la libération
des otages ni le droit d'Israël à se
défendre ce qui été jugé comme une
infamie par le représentant de de l'État
hébreu qui s'est opposé au texes tout
comme les États-Unis ou encore
l'Allemagne qui s'est abstenu par
exemple mais la France elle tout en
regrettant des manques donc l'absence de
h Terl s'est montré moins sourcilleuse
que quand elle était au Conseil de
sécurité et elle a voté oui comment ça
s'explique ben rien ne serait justifieré
les souffrances des civil dit Nicolas de
rivière et la situation à Gaza est
désastreuse selon lui ce qui est un
argument un peu jésuitique parce que
c'était quand même le cas il y a une
dizaine de jours c'était déjà désastreux
et il y avait déjà des victimes civiles
mais la France on voit bien depuis
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron en
façon à sa visite plutôt en Israël
essaie de reprendre un rôle de jouer un
rôle peut-être une médiation future au
Proche Orient a donc besoin de donner
des gages à la fois au monde arabe et
puis de marquer son indépendance et
c'est pas sûr toutefois que cela suffise
merci matthie faisz référence à la
réaction de l'ambassadeur israélien aux
Nations Unies on écoute justement
guildan aujourd'hui est un jour qui
restera dans les mémoires comme un jour
d'infamie nous avons tous constaté que
les Nations Unies n'ont plus la moindre
légitimité il la moindre pertinence
cette organisation a été fondée à la
suite de l'Holocauste dans le but de
prévenir les atrocit
pourtant le spectacle auquel nous venons
d'assister prouve sans l'ombre d'un
doute que l'ONU c'est malheureusement
tragiquement engagé non pas à prévenir
mais à garantir de nouvelles atrocités
em depuis comment alors on va pas
surestimer le rôle de l'enu aujourd'hui
on a suffisamment débattu autour de
cette table
mais comment vous analyser ce qui s'est
passé vendredi soir et est-ce que ça
fragilise en partie Israël ou est-ce que
de toute façon le cabinet de guerre
suivra sa sa route quelqu même si on
considère qu'il y a pas de stratégie à
long TER pas certain que le cabinet de
guerre écoute réellement la manière dont
le vote s'est déroulé même si ils ont
demandé la démission officielle
d'Antonio Gutiérrez par rapport à cela
et par rapport à la prise de parole qui
avait précédé cette assemblée générale
moi je l'analyse aussi comme un déliton
de l'Europe il faut quand même avoir à
l'esprit queil y a pas eu une position
unanime vous avez rappelé que la France
a voté le texte tout comme l'Espagne qui
préside le Conseil de l'Union européenne
quatre pays
sont ont voté contre l'Autriche la
Croatie la République tchèque et si je
ne m'abuse la l'Allemagne et l'Italie
sont obstenus l'Hongrie l'Autriche la
Croatie pardon et la République et
l'Allemagne et l'Italie se sont absolu
donc c'est une une preuve par l'absurde
de l'inexistence de la politique
étrangère et de sécurité commune alors
que Joseph Borel faisait mine de montrer
que l'Union européenne voulait être aux
avantposte pour au moins obtenir cette
rêve humanitaire le deuxième élément
c'est que il y a effectivement une
pression de la part des États-Unis très
forte qui a joué dans les coulisses des
nations- Unies mais qui n'a pas
forcément fonctionné car un certain
nombre de pays n'ont pas
forcément enfin ont voté la résolution
alors que les Américains ne voulaient
pas qu'elle soit votée et N et pas
seulement des pays entre guillemets dans
l'avantage serait de porter une estocade
contre les États-Unis je pense notamment
à la Russie à la Chine à l'Inde mais
d'autres pays comme le Brésil
l'Argentine ou l'Afrique du Sud qui et
un certain nombre de pays africains qui
se sont donc opposés à la résolution
donc c'est une preuve encore une fois
que on doit en être je crois à plus de
200 résolutions nuisiennes depuis la
première de 1948 en tout cas celle qui
structure la la la nécessité de deux
états la résolution 1981 que l'ONU et
bien évidemment avec la plus vieille
mission de maintien de la paix l'onus
depuis 1948 n'arrive pas à obtenir un
résultat escomté ce qui me fait dire que
d'autres attendent au tournant avec une
approche un peu différente je pense
notamment à la Chine qui pourrait comme
elle l'a fait avec l'Iran et l'Arabie
Saoudite faire une proposition de
dialogue autre que celle des pays
occidentaux Jean Paul dans dans la
foulée de cette résolution il y a eu la
la proposition du ramas concernant les
les otages un échange des des otages
alors on est à plus de 230 otage selon
les derniers décomtes contre tous les
prisonniers palestiniens il y a je crois
pas eu de réponse ou de réaction de
Benjamin netaniahou à ma à ma
connaissance avant de répondre à votre
question juste un mot sur ce qui s'est
passé à
la n'est pas c'est pas la première fois
que dans un blocage du Conseil de
sécurité c'est l'assemblée générale qui
essaie de prendre la main la première
fois c'était en 1950 avec la guerre de
Corée et ce qu'on appelle la résolution
àon parenthèse refermée en ce qui
concerne les otage contre prisonnier je
je pense que quand on lit lapr
israélienne il est clair que des
négociations ont lueu en ce moment
indirectement mais c'est impossible que
il y a une phrase de de naniahou qui est
très CLA il a dit nous nous examinons
toutes les options tion pour libérer les
hotages dans toutes les options il y a
évidemment la proposition duas qui ne
date pas d'il y a quelques jours elle
elle a été faite dès le début làement é
manière CLA donc c'est évidemment il y a
des pressions en Israël dans la dans des
certains segments de l'opinion publique
pour faire en sorte que on le fasse
c'est très clair d'autres évidemment s'y
opposent pour plein de raisons mais en
tout cas je suis à peu près convaincu
que les négociations doivent avoir lieu
et peut-être c'est une des raisons aussi
peut-être qui fait que cette cette
offensive soit encore un peu parcellaire
un peu tactique mais sans vraiment avoir
un objectif parce que je pense qu'il
faut quand même régler C cette carte en
main plus et en plus la question euh ça
a été dit tout à l'heure mais dans les
prisonniers palestiniens il y en a
environ 4005 5000 euh il y a pas il y a
loin il y a une partie Hamas mais les
autres c'est du fata et il y a quelques
personnages il ont deux et un en
particulier qui ont qui n'ont pas été
assassinés par euh par Israël à l'époque
des assassinbl en en en en 2000 2001 il
a été prisonnier c'est Marwan margoui en
200 de et c'est un des personnages qui
pourrait jouer un rôle politique et
d'ailleurs qui a joué un rôle politique
de sa prison pendant très longtemps et
donc peut-être qu'il y a quelque chose
de de possible dans cette affaire mais
cela dit je pense que le comité de le
cabinet de guerre est arquebouté sur
l'idée qu'on ira au bout de la force
d'autant plus qu'il est il a une
coalition avec des suprémacistes juifs
qui ont envie d'aller très loin et qui
vont je je dire un mot un peu terrible
mais profiter de cette situation pour
aller encore plus loin en 6 jourdanie en
terme de colonisation donc on est dans
cette situation extrêmement confuse et
je pense qu'il faut que la communauté
internationale bouge sinon on va aller
dans cette votre photo de derrière cette
cette fumée et et ces destructions on va
vraiment dans cette direction Patricia
lmonè justement sur la S Jordanie le le
rôle de certains colon extrémiste c'est
c'est aussi une un élément de l'équation
à prendre à prendre en compte en ce
moment c'est un élément très important
parce que aujourd'hui alors quand nous
sommes fixés nous avons les les yeux
fixés sur ce qui se passe à Gaza
effectivement si Jordanie euh les les
colons qui sont en fait des
nationalistes messianiques qui veulent
une Israël qui va jusqu'au Jourdain
jusqu'en Jordanie et qui espère enfin
pas tous mais la grande majorité
souhaite ils le disent ouvertement
expulser tous ces Palestiniens qu'ils
retournent ils le disent totalement
ouvertement qu'on vous les rencontrer
qu'il retourne qu'il partent en Jordanie
puisqu'il y a beaucoup de Palestiniens
souvenez-vous la nagba he ce grand ce
moment qui est très marqué qui marque
tous les Palestiniens on ne peut pas
comprendre ce qui se passe dans ces
territoires sans avoir en mémoire ce qui
s'est passé c'est l'exil c'est l'exode
enfin l'exil et pareil une partie qui
est partie en Égypte et qui s'est
retrouvé une autre à Gaza coincée et
bien on ne peut pas régler je crois le
le problème aujourd'hui sans pression et
et sans faire en sorte que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en S Jordanie s'arrête
village attaqué village vidé et aussi si
vous voulez c'est pas c'est pas que les
gentil Palestiniens qui sont expulsés il
y a aussi si vous voulez des
Palestiniens excédés qui n'en peuvent
plus ou qui ont la rage et qui ont la
haine et bien aussi qui qui attaquent
des policiers qui attaquent des colons
donc on est une situation d'extrême
tension avec une volonté pour les dures
autour de benvir et bien de de d'en
profiter et et de et d'en fait de vider
la S Jordanie de ces Palestiniens ou en
tout cas de les rassembler dans les
villes dans les quelques grandes villes
qui existent afin de de participer de
faire un nettoyage ethnique quoi allez
il nous reste une dizaine de minutes
propose de revenir sur un autre fait
majeur de ces dernières 24 heures avec
Steve Jourdain qui va nous rejoindre sur
ce plateau l'assaut Steve bonsoir
l'assaut d'un aéroport au Dagestan hier
soir une foule qui s'attaque à un avion
en provenance de tel avive oui une foule
qui prend àut l'aéroport de makashkala
la capitale de cette république russe à
majorité musulmane sur les images qu'on
va voir on voit des dizaines de
manifestants proalestiniens mener tout
simplement une chasse aux Juifs à
l'intérieur même de l'aéroport on peut
attendre des cris comme Allah Akbar on
distingue aussi plusieurs drapeaux
palestiniens alors pourquoi sont-ils
dans le terminal et bien parce qu'ils
ont appris qu'un avion de la compagnie
russe Red Wings allait atterrir sur le
tarmac effectivement l'appareil se pose
à 19h17 heure locale l'avion faisait une
escale et devait repartir dans la foulée
pour Moscou sur le coup de 21h les ces
manifestants qui se sont introduits sur
le tarmac oui on va voir cette foule
foncée vers l'appareil un steward
demande aux passagers de revenir à
l'intérieur pour s'enfermer et se
protéger les manifestants donc
envahissent le tamac certains jettent
des pierres d'autres recherch tout
simplement les passagers en en voitant
qui cherche à l'intérieur d'un réacteur
saiton jamais ce qu'on voit c'est en
quelque sorte le début de la fin de
l'événement Thomas puisque ça fait
plusieurs heures que les aimetiers
encerclent l'aéroport ils ont installé
des barrage pour contrôler ceux qui
sortent du terminal à un moment ils ont
cru avoir mis la main sur un juif
[Musique]
écouter voilà il s'agissait en fait d'un
ressortissant oubeek bilan de ces
événements pas de blessé ni de victime à
déploré côté passager une soantaine
d'individus ont été interpellés par la
police avec évidemment un action
internationale oui on précise le
Dagestan est une république du Caucase
il partage sa frontière avec la la tie
de Kadirov on compte 3 millions
d'habitants le pays est connu pour être
l'un des repères de l'islam radical ces
dernières années d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de dagestanais sont allés
rejoindre les rangs de l'État islamique
pendant les événements hier le
gouvernement israélien a appelé Vladimir
Poutine à protéger les juifs et les
ressortissant israéliens dans la région
on compte environ 400 familles juives au
Dagestan aujourd'hui on a appris qu'un
peu qu'un peu plus tôt hier dans la
journée un centre culturel juif de la
région avait été incendié est-ce que
justement Vladimir Poutine va ou peut
contribuer à faire baisser les tensions
on va voir ce communiqué publié cet
après-midi par Moscou la Russie accuse
aujourd'hui l'Ukraine d'avoir joué un
rôle clé dans les émeutes au Dagestan
émeutes qui seraiit le résultat d'une
provocation planifiée et conduite de
l'extérieur Poutine a visiblement
visiblement pris son parti he dans la
guerre Israël ramasse la semaine
dernière une délégation de
l'organisation terroriste a été
accueilli à Moscou à droite sur la photo
Abou marzou l'un des chefs du Hamas il
est en compagnie du vice-ministre russe
des Affaires étrangères et du numéro 2
de la diplomatie iranienne merci
beaucoup Steve jourin pour toutes ces
informations Patrice saléonère Vladimir
Poutine n-il en train d'une certaine
façon de lâcher Israël non je ne pense
pas euh je pense que ce qu'il y a en
Russie depuis très longtemps qui remonte
à la période stalinienne un fort
sentiment antijuif disonsle comme ça
enfin le le le c'est c'est très présent
dans la culture donc on le sait très
bien l'impérialisme russe qui s qui se
manifeste dans toutes les républiques du
Caucase et d'Asie centrale puisqu'on
parle jamais du colonialisme russe mais
ma fois c'est l'occasion d'en parler et
bien s'accompagne aussi de cette
propagande alors ce qui est important
dans les événements qui qui se passent
je ne pense pas que Moscou enfin je peux
me tromper hein soit en jeu je pense
qu'il s'agit beaucoup d'un fort
ressentiment d'une partie de la
population musulmane à l'encontre
d'Israël une population qui est
bibronnée par les réseaux sociaux avec
ce qui se passe à Gaza et je crois qu'il
ne faudrait aujourd'hui ça ça doit nous
attirer attirer notre attention parce
que il y a une cisure dans le monde
aujourd'hui il y a nous qui avons notre
prisme quand même occidental et le reste
du monde qui a un autre prisme et qui
est bibronné par d'autres vidéos que
celle que nous voyons et là je crois
qu'il est urgent que l'on fasse preuve
de réflexion et de retenue dans dans
dans nos analyses et nos propos et
Emmanuel depis les images qu'on vient de
voir ça renforce enfin peut-être que mon
analyse un peu binaire mais forcément
sur le territoire israélien le le enfin
voilà le sentiment la légitimité de se
défendre aujourd'hui oui alors il faut
quand même avoir à l'esprit que il y a
eu déjà quelques soucis avec la
communauté juive russe puisque l'ex
grand Rabin de Moscou avait prévenu que
les Juifs devaient quitter la Russie car
ils a être instrumentalisé on sait que
il y a une forte communauté juive
également en Ukraine donc ça fait le jeu
de je suis pas certain qu'il faillit
voir la main de Moscou mais ça fait jeu
de Moscou d'ailleurs ralen méchal pour
revenir à lui ou à bouarzou ont était
félicité car l'attention médiatique est
détournée de l'Ukraine au profit du
nouveau conflit ou en tout cas présenté
comme le conflit qui génère une pression
médiatique maximale enfin il faut avoir
à l'esprit qu'il y a toujours eu un
sentiment en tuif il y a surtout eu une
montée de salafisme dans la région hein
depuis la relance de la création d'un
émirat du Caucase Nord en 2017 avec
faut-il le rappeler 15 à 20 millions de
musulmans qui se trouvent en Russie avec
le président Poutine qui en joue euh il
a réuni en mai dernier un sommet euh
économique un forum économique entre la
Russie et le monde islamique à Kazan au
Tatarstan pour essayer de montrer que
lui aussi on va avoir cette relation et
puis dernier point euh il y a quelques
jours le président de l'autre République
euh donc fédéré tchenen avait lui aussi
appelé à se venger euh de l'État
d'Israël ouais et puis alors là
évidemment c'est complexe Israël qui a
besoin de la Russie parce que la Russie
la Russie contrôle euh l'espace aérien
syrien et laisse pour l'instant Israël
intervenir pour empêcher on va dire
l'alimentation en en armes notamment du
du du hzbolah donc là on est dans un
dans un jeu subtile entre Israël et la
Russie Jean Jean-Paul chagolo bien sûr
parce que la Russie comme ça bienent
comme tu l'as dit c'est très important
engrange aussi pas mal de choses puisque
finalement on parle plus de l'Ukraine et
puis euh euh ça lui permet d'avoir un
jeu diplomatique sur un plateau en
quelque sorte mais en même temps elle
veut pas se couper je suis d'accord avec
avec l'Israël faut pas oublier qu' a une
communauté russe très importante en en
Israël c'est sans doute la plus
importante avec les Marocains et ils ont
un poids énorme donc tout ceci est
complexe mais dans tout ce qu'on vient
de dire cette complexité on peut
l'appréhender de manière rationnelle
mais à un moment donné il y a quelque
chose qui va nous échapper et quelque
chose qui va nous échapper qui va nous
conduire sans doute vers des vers des
déséquilibres et des violences possibles
autrement dit c'est c'est tellement
comple les chev dans lequel nous sommes
sur plan politico diplomatique que
malheureusement il suffirait d'un
incident grave ou quelque chose pour que
ça bascule particulier à ce qui pourrait
se passer du côté du hzbollah des choses
comme ça donc on est
vra plus on va arriver et plus on va
arriver vers vers une intensification de
cette offensive si elle a lieu enfin je
dans dans son ampleur plus ce genre de
chose va se passer et ça c'est c'est
extrêmement préoccupant dans les
prochains jours c'est pas c'est pas dans
donc c'est pour ça que vous dites il
faut une initiative diplomatique alors
peut-être qu'elle peut venir de la Chine
je ne sais pas mais est-ce que est-ce
qu'elle est en germe cette initiative
diplomatique ou pas vous savez elle elle
est on balbusie l'assemblée générale a
balbué quelque chose l'Europe à la fin a
communiqué au sens propre du terme a
balbuer c'estàdire qu'ils ont rajouté il
faudrait une conférence de paix mais
c'est tout sans s sans qu'il ait quoi
que ce soit d'autre pour pour
l'organiser donc pour l'instant nous il
y a il y a rien mais pourtant c'est ce
qu'il faudrait qu'il se passe parce que
sinon je dis on va très vite être son
déséquilibre et donc s'il y a pas ce
retour aux politiqu dans les prochains
prochains jours euh on va avoir que des
commentaires de de désastres et de
violence on est vraiment dans un tunnel
actuellement si on n'en sort pas et
juste un mot encore pour dire que on on
répète sans arrêt à juste titre que
Israël a le droit de se défendre mais il
faut ajouter de la même façon que les
Palestiniens ont le droit de se défendre
notamment en s jourdanie ils sont sous
occupation et donc on va voir aussi là
quelque chose qui va se passer car les
Palestiniens ont le droit de se défendre
eux aussim c'est ce qui va se passer
donc voilà on est dans cette complexité
donc pour l'instant je ne vois
évidemment malheureusement aucune issue
politique alors que c'est ça qui devrait
se passer un mot de de de l'une et
l'autre sur une issue politique pour une
issue politique oui évidemment c'est
c'est essentiel et surtout que si le
monde se mettez en marche sur cette on a
des moyens pour faire pression sur les
protagonismes de cette affaire ils sont
financiers oui alors notamment notamment
les moyens du Qatar d'un côté qui
finance m mais même l'Amérique peut
faire pression aussi sur Israël en
prenant des PR caution parce que je ne
suis pas sûr qu'Israël ne se tourne pas
dans ce cas-là vers la Chine ou vers la
Russie oui alors il faut évidemment
avoir à l'esprit que les États-Unis sont
les gros plus gros pouvilleurs 260
milliards depuis de dollars depuis
l'indépendance don près de 130 milliards
pour pour l'armement mais je crois que
la soft policy ou l'influence douce de
l'Europe peut comme à Madrid en 91 à
auson en 93 imaginons aussi une nouvelle
conférence de paix telle qu'elle avait
été proposée par l'Arabie Saoudite en
2002 peut effectivement offrir une
perspective en tout cas c'est ce que
Emmanuel Macron je crois a mais vous
nous disiez uninstant que l'Europe elle
apparît plutôt divisée je je dis bien
c'est de manière objective c'est le
c'est c'est un constat mais de manière
prospective il faudrait qu'il y ait une
position qui soit proposé par l'Europe
qui vise à ce qu'il y ait un règlement
du conflit qui ne tienne pas seulement
compte du droit d'Israël à se défendre
ou des droits des gazaou à se défendre
mais d'une solution qui implique aussi
la si Jordanie h c'est ça la question
c'est pas seulement la question du Hamas
c'est aussi la question d'une
temporalité politique qui depuis 2005
est figée enjordanie merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat Patricia
aléonia je rappelle le titre de votre
livre au cœur du chaos livre publié aux
éditions
au à bientôt sur sur public sa